no one has a voice and an accent like
you
and when i hear your voice i am
immediately enveloped in this
sensuality and joy and by the way
being cute funny and sexy is like one of
the hardest combinations to ever pull
off and
that's the embodiment of who you are and
it's so fun to watch you in the hitman's
wife's bodyguard movie because you're
just a total badass action star
and it makes me think of desperado which
was a movie
where you and antonio banderas who are
back together again
in this new movie will you like take me
back to that moment because i thought
that movie really changed the industry
robert rodriguez it was a a new type of
filmmaking
yes he had done a movie only with seven
thousand
dollars and he invented some special
effects that were very
um low very cheap
special effects like um he will put the
camera
on a um
wheelchair you know to get the smooth
shot because he didn't have a dolly
and he raised the money by
lending his body for experimentation
drug experimentation and it was a really
interesting story
and desperado was his first
hollywood movie uh antonio at the time
was like
you know the sex symbol and i was just
so lucky that
i got that opportunity and that shot
and i couldn't believe myself it almost
you know i
i had been told over and over and over
you'll never make it in this town there
you will only play a prostitute uh drug
dealer
wife or girlfriend and
uh housekeeper you know because there's
no other roles for you
and then here comes robert rodriguez who
gave us the opportunity for latinos to
have other kinds of roles
and that started my career what was that
like hearing that i mean that just
frustrates me and i want to scratch the
faces off of people who would say that
to you
what did you say to yourself when you
would hear that
it's really surprising that people that
are in such high positions are so stupid
[Laughter]
i was thinking there's 40 million
latinos in this country
they really care about the money well
there's some on top
huge potential market here and
they were not seeing it and i was like
wow
one time i remember there was one
studio executive and he said to me in
these words
you know what you were born
on the wrong side of the border had you
been
born you know on the right side of the
border
probably you would be the biggest star
in the world
but no matter how beautiful anybody
thinks you are
no matter how good of an actress you are
the minute you open your mouth
the audience are just going to be
reminded of their mates
and that's what he said to me but they
smartened up
they really did and i think it took
people like you
to change the minds you're so right on a
business level
um you know that's such an ignorant
statement
and um one time i was told by a casting
director
i was like 14 or 15 and child
star you know has been at 14
um and i walked into an office and the
casting director said do you even know
how lucky you are
to be in this room right now nobody
wants you
so just act very grateful and i was like
i am i i am thank you and
what i love hearing about your story is
you come off
as the most empowered loving
open vivacious effervescent woman
and if we can only take those kind of
experiences
and try to change minds without becoming
bitter
or being angry about it that to me is
rocket fuel um to say
okay i hear you but i still want to keep
going i don't want to let that stop my
dreams
and so thank you for thank you
is it okay if i ask you a question
please am i allowed
are you kidding it's a conversation so
i'm gonna interview you i think
i love that but i really want to to know
this and i think
there's going to be a lot of people who
are going to want to know that i
i've had it hard and i know how hard it
is but i was older
and i don't know any other child actor
that had so much attention like you did
and that had to go through those hard
times and the rejection
at 14 um i
i have a teenager and i have four
stepchildren that have gone through that
age
and they have so much scrutination right
now you know
with all the social media and stuff i
really want to know
how how did you find the strength
at 14 to keep fighting
uh i will answer by saying
it was the best uh training ground for
social media
i will say that uh i think
that dealing with rejection as a young
person
is something that everyone is going to
feel um when you're that age
rejection is rejection and
to have the perspective of what is real
and
important who do you need to know the
truth
to not feel like you have to prove
everything all the time to everyone
out there and you just have to look
to the people who are very real around
you
and make sure in their eyes that you're
okay it took me
uh harsh lessons to learn that but it's
a great way to navigate social media
if it only becomes real if you let it
hurt you
yes yes which is harkens back full
circle
to you as you know an up-and-coming
actress and then i went through the same
cycle of having to hear things
that weren't easy to hear but you turn
it into your strengths and i think
even become more compassionate to
everyone around you
if you didn't like the way that felt
then you speak to everyone else with
even
more grace even more compliments even
more kindness
and you say great thank you you just
told me you just taught me a lesson
on how not to ever treat another person
so thank you very much for that lesson
let's add to that come on how fun it is
that they said to you and to me nobody
wants you
and we're part of the generation
although you're much younger than me
of actresses that also became
entrepreneurs
producers you know we are unstoppable
girl
we know so much
more and you know they are not gonna
last
and maybe it's all really great training
for motherhood too because i think about
all the lessons i learned
and your daughter valentina is 13.
um what what is she into now by the way
i can tell you a couple of things and
only because it's you
she is um she loves perfumes
she's crazy about perfumes she loves
you and she loves lana del rey and
because she loves music and uh
she is she knows so much about
horoscopes she he's into horoscopes and
and
she's quite impressive i mean i have a
lot of people who ask her can you do
mine can you do my chart can you do my
chart
and she's done your shot i've never had
my chart done you know by the way
and we'll send you we'll send you your
chart oh
well we have one minute left and by the
way um
i have to tell you watching you do your
stunts in the hitman's
wife's bodyguard movie was so
incredible what was it like to do all
your own stunts
no joke it's hard and scary
how did you do it i know but it gives me
a lot of
pride to be you know in my 50s and still
be able to do the stunts and
like yeah i'm gonna show them i can
still do it and i did
i was in a lot of pain the next morning
but like
right in the moment you know i i
had a lot of adrenaline i have nothing
but admiration for you
like i used to be able to pull off like
a charlie's angels and now
i would be like in traction the next day
like hanging upside down in a
chiropractor's office
[Music]
you